Sebastian Maniscalco in studio here in
Jim Norton Sam Roberts what's going on
man what is going on I just flew in and
I'm in New York City yeah yeah yeah yeah
are you doing a gig ooh just promoting I
am doing Colbert tomorrow oh gosh time
so I'm special right now on Showtime
that's airing and just doing just doing
a bunch of promotion no since I've seen
I just seen you and you're just thinking
about that as as you walk by I haven't
seen you by the way you look great I
thank you I didn't know you'd lost all
this weight I haven't seen you in a
while yeah maybe the Dice Clay years and
that's got to be 2004 maybe so since we
did the gate together yeah I didn't know
we were in Vegas together and you and
Jim had opened up for him multiple times
prior to me doing it so I didn't know
the whole dice thing like we go to the
mall
yeah oh you had to do the whole thing
didn't you know you're shopping yeah you
know like Vegas with dice and I'm like
this is gonna be great
go to the pool we're gonna go to
nightclubs and he's like no we're gonna
go shop for couches so yeah
try disappointing it ha ha ha and then
he make you buy like XL hoodies to match
his he's got the weirdest idea of
friendship he's such an odd guy I love
him and he changed my life but you how
long did you tour with him for two years
and yeah we would do this excel like we
would go to a harley-davidson it would
be a spot and he just go on yeah take it
yeah I get the pro deal that's right the
pro do you remember the broad we
certainly do yeah nice we just go in
there and steal he would it was ten
million dollars he's just stealing
[ __ ] hoodies so would you just go in
the store you put it on you walk out I
wouldn't lie to do it as a Dyson I can't
do this so uh yeah we had a lot of good
times together
yeah he's a fun guy man he's a really
fun dude then he loves sweets yeah you
were gonna candy store well I came to
work out then we go get a Slurpee yeah I
think the best stories to of it that he
goes into open houses and just runs up
and down the steps and [ __ ] is crazy but
this is what happens when you don't
drink you know I mean like if you're not
on the road drinking what else are you
gonna do right you got to find other
[ __ ] yeah make you happy and make you
feel good about yeah
ridiculous [ __ ] yeah yeah but he would
do that he would you'd work out and this
is before I worked out and he was a
[ __ ] Kenny or happy face and they
would have to have a giant Starbucks
with the whipped cream and the action
mocha chip as he was [ __ ] extra mocha
you're like draining and they'd had this
giant chocolate treat afterwards but any
calories he burned working out he would
just immediately get the back and you
can't work out it had a [ __ ] 1800
calorie beverage uh-huh but he was a fun
guy man and you learned the crowd had
they treated the audiences I was a
decent success with them uh yeah it was
tough it was one of those things where I
got actually thrown off a little bit
where I ended my set early and I came
off and he he wasn't happy at all he's
like what are you doing you know no
matter how bad it's going you finish
your time so you know I mean it was like
why didn't they like you he wasn't dice
as soon as I got out there and it was a
hostile crowd they wanted to see him and
it threw my act off and timing off and I
got off a little bit early and he set me
straight which you know I went like I
said a lot you know working with him and
his crowds and turn with him so yeah it
was a great experience
yeah when did you start to get
established the blinks I was watching
your comedians and cars with Seinfeld
last night and like just listening to
Jerry talk about the fact that you're
one of if not his favorite comedian like
he goes to you when he wants to laugh
like at what point did that stuff start
to happen for you I don't know I mean I
met Jerry about a year and a half ago I
got them comedy club in here in New York
City we came fast friends and asked me
to do the show and I'd say about maybe
two years
those things started like that started
happening I've been doing it since 1998
and just kind of working on the clubs
and working my act out and you know
doing stand-up and yeah I guess about
two years ago things started to kind of
kick in I guess Sebastian really has his
own audience though like they're they're
not necessarily even just comedy fans
the fans of his it's crazy
but I was just telling him that the ex
detectives that we have that works
security here yeah last night they were
when I did Kreischer on mass they'll
come over and they like you know who's
[ __ ] coming in tomorrow Sebastian
Maniscalco is going to be the try just
don't try to meet him and I'm like they
don't know who Christ was they don't
know all comics are but they're [ __ ]
crazy about him how did you respond to
that like after all these years of just
you know club club club club and just
trying when it started when you kind of
blow up it was the Showtime special
right the first one that really began it
yeah you know that Showtime special
definitely you know got the ball rolling
people started to share my comedy
amongst their friends I have a big
Italian following so it'd be like a
couple would come and then they would
bring their parents and then they would
bring the neighborhood so you know they
just get the swell of people starting to
come to the show because they're
relating to the family upbringing you
know immigrant background and it was
very familiar to people so I guess so
that that that part of the comedy
community was a little bit underserved
as far as like family and stuff like
that not not that I'm know like I talked
about family but in that sense of being
very specific yet very broad but you
also clean - yeah you can bring like you
can bring your parents like that and you
get a galley Gaffigan - who appeals to
that way you can bring whoever you want
you guys are in this relationship yeah
but also I think there's people who like
Sebastian that they think the world's a
little screwed up but they don't know
exactly how to articulate it me like
they feel like they did some things
right and now they look at the world and
they don't get it that's what they get
out of him I think I think they they
feel that he's saying what they wish
they could say King that's right yeah
you know it's just it's submarine I
think about you much I don't even think
of
right now when you articulated like that
I guess you're right I mean it's just
observation alook in that the world like
we all do and kind of report in the news
on stage and and saying in a way that
and I I tend to do a lot of physical
movement too so I don't know I don't
know what it is it just a lot a lot of
things that I never really thought about
but uh it's nice to have the police
department
did you get away with murder but how did
that will you working clean when you
when you open for dice
yeah I'd swear yeah here and there but
it's uh you know I'm not talking about a
lot of sexual activity anything like
that it's just kind of you know they SiC
gay I went to Home Depot and this is
what I saw
or my wife is doing X Y & Z when when
you're when you're torment dice and you
see what dice is doing and then these
fans are being hostile is there a party
that's like oh man I got a dirtier stuff
in my act this is what people want I'm
not what I'm doing isn't isn't one
people one I mean I know I didn't I
didn't do that so this is my act if you
like it you like it if you don't you
don't I didn't adjust it to the
environment I said you know this is what
I think is funny right if these people
think it's funny that's great but that
one night I think it was in a casino in
Washington they weren't having to adjust
you're acting like Home Depot family so
I'm gonna come on your face a little you
put your head in the frozen yogurt
machine nice really is a genius yeah
yeah he told me he told me he's a genius
that's a funny [ __ ] moment in a
couple times and he's he's very well
aware that wordplay he loves that [ __ ]
dude that when he said that foot you
Hendra [ __ ] it's only the frozen yogurt
machine emoji what a brilliant way he
always finds a new way to be filthier
edges it's always different do you take
your openers out shopping with you cuz
that's new what you came up you know
what I don't I'm not a big social guy
yeah the role you need the entourage no
I don't I don't bring a guy I use kind
of like a local guy oh you don't have
your money to put my hotel on a [ __ ]
airfare dinner
Martin yeah smart I don't I I get that
like bringing a guy who you might get
along with our girl you might get along
with I get bad but I don't know and I'm
on the road I can tend to be a little
little bit of a loner and not wanna have
to hang out with somebody for lunch or
anything like that and what do you do
are you with your wife or do you travel
by yourself manager uh my wife and
myself so my wife will come to the you
know the New York's the Miami's of the
world and Lynn joy joy the city not the
Akron's yeah so uh yeah I got married
about three years ago so my wife and I
are very very tight and she enjoys
coming with me and she says she's an
artist so she's got a flexible schedules
where she could do that that's great how
did she react to you kind of blowing up
because you said it was like two years
ago that things really started to blow
up which leaves you that's not the
person that necessarily she married you
know what I mean yeah like his life
changes yeah life changes we've been
together seven years but my wife is
involved with you know my career she
kind of takes the lead on the creative
the design stuff if we have to do a DVD
cover if we have to do a backdrop for a
stage she's heavily involved in that and
you know we've always kind of been the
same couple but now just have a little
bit more activity around us so right
right so it's it's still good this'll go
ahead when you want when you have
somebody open for you do you make sure
like okay all I want the guy to be kind
of clean like you don't want some
[ __ ] dirt you know I mean you know
and someone what are you looking for
Jimmy a couple new dates I do have but
know if the president was timing is
anything over for I'm gonna lay down you
go for good clean minutes and finished
repeating jokes no I don't I I whatever
the guy does oh you don't care okay yeah
that's fine for me I don't edit him or I
don't say you can't do this that or the
other thing I just I just kind of get
the best guy whoever's working in the
area and and I look at some tapes I
cannot oh you actually watched a tape
tapes 1989 hello guys videos funny here
just girls funny I bring her bring her
on so ya know I mean IIIi don't like to
have like a really dirty guy sure but
whatever whatever they're doing and
think it's funny let's do it have you
ever had an open it didn't work were you
like I got to get rid of this person
I've had an over where I said maybe
we're not going to use this person again
but we just don't call again
but as they're doing their thing it's
I'm kind of always listening to see I
want the person to do like a good show
people spending a lot of money right of
course this comes from my father who is
actively involved in my career every
time I come back to Chicago he's you
know like and people paying $89 you are
a good show from top to bottom the
opener wasn't so good so you know we got
to switch him out that's a good point
though people want the whole [ __ ]
thing to be good you don't the guy in
front of you tanking yeah I always
thought that person was supposed to be
really good to kind of get the curl
going and then you go on do your thing
do you care about the Cubs I'm going to
the game all you are I'm going tell me
I'm a Sox fan but I'm in World Series in
Chicago Cubs 71 years you got no right
which K me on to I'm going to Friday and
Saturday have you ever been to Wrigley
Field Regal I was I went once i'ma shat
my pants I had to it was I was doing a
comedy fest acog Oh Comedy Festival in
like 2000 and I'm there and I'm watching
the game and by the third inning I had
like a bunch of coffees and I'm like
it's time to go and I had to rush back
to the hotel you did [ __ ] you can do it
in the stadium not ask us ting stadium
bathrooms no you don't shoulda stayed in
bathroom however would you [ __ ] in the
stadium I've never done that
no I've ever I'm not a big stadium guy
right I don't do a lot of sports events
but if I had to go I think I pull in
Norton and kids get the car
that's what it's called ever you leave
somewhere go home and [ __ ] is called an
organ are ya pull the Norton we gotta go
drop at Norton no no no [ __ ] in the
hotel um your your special that's on
Showtime right now it's not short time I
demand right now yeah it was filmed what
is it so you did a seven night run at
the Beacon right yeah and is this
special one of those seven nights or is
it pieced together it's one of those
seven nights we shot two of the shows
okay and we used one basically The Late
Show on a Saturday we used that one and
cut a couple jokes in from the first one
which I thought were a little bit better
did you worship I was called why would
you do that and it's on now yeah it's
good
did you wear the same shirt throughout
the entire run just in case so you had
everything double of everything
so I sweat too a shirt and then we
dispose of that shirt and then we put a
new one with the new one back out I'm
very into clothing as a strangest
question I've ever heard we get $7 oh I
would have never occurred to me right
cool you're there for a week did you
perspire yeah wear the same shirt every
night if you're gonna film a special no
but the risk what that is like to do
seven first of all it's such an amazing
run seven show at the bacon that's the
armorer edibles that's since we all had
a brothers yeah it really is and but to
do seven shows when you're filming two
of them is scary because weren't the
Friday Early Show like that did you have
any shows you I [ __ ] wish we got that
one yeah yeah yeah I think you're always
gonna have that you're like Dan and
Wednesday night was really good actually
the last show Sunday night was the I
think the best show that we didn't get
but uh yeah we should we filmed the two
on Saturday and yeah I had my two shirts
ready to go did you have been a good
dresser I mean I won the first thing I
know about Sebastian years ago you were
sued on stage he looked really really
good and people do respond to that you
know they're like well he looks like he
belongs there you know it goes along
with people they feel like they're like
it just feels like a bigger event yeah I
don't know I always enjoyed dressing up
I used to wear maybe a suit but it was
too hot and I like to be a little bit
more mobile
I switched it up a little bit I know the
younger guys don't do that though you
seem coming on big baggy shorts and [ __ ]
they look like they yeah just came from
the gym I slow so kid was literally
wearing gym shorts the other night it's
wrong fake something okay [ __ ] actually
was somebody who looks up the big J okay
and then also they don't go for energy
did you know is that like the younger
guys some of them don't lean back you
know the part of me I think some of the
comedians if that's naturally who you
are but I think some of them are afraid
it's a defense mechanism I think so and
they're scared and they're afraid that
they think that makes them look like wow
look at this genius just a conduit for
brilliance like they're afraid that if
they a mode it looks like they're over
selling it and I think some of them are
scared of the audience and they don't
know how to comfortably do it so they
just kind of stand there like dime-store
India you know this if it's not that's
who you are that's fine but a lot and
that's not how they are I also have a
theory that a lot of the younger comics
that do that like the deliver jokes as
if they're not joking it's a way to do
it so that if it doesn't get any laughs
they're like yeah I wasn't joking oh
yeah yeah shoot then why you're standing
up there yeah what he's doing is the
point and or not okay
I don't know well you but you're right
about the other clothing everything I
think the clothing like wow you know it
really does help you look at a dice who
certainly didn't wear a suit or Kinison
or Louie who looks like he just [ __ ]
rolled at a fan like there is Nellie's
soup boy though what's that
Luiz know where it suits is he really
yeah you started what what on stage yeah
on stage when he does shows now
he said he decided as an adult it gives
people at $89 worth they they're paying
that much for a ticket they want to see
a guy who's dressed well you know
they're perform maybe maybe not I don't
know I grew up watching dice so he was
always theatrical in his dress yeah new
leather coat every special yeah yes
special hmm I think that the best dice
leather coat was the MTV Music Awards
with the with the the black and white
zebra oh yes yeah I'm saying [ __ ]
something I was like a rug in Scarface
there he is like vertical stress the man
that nice man he really was he was he
warrant without shame and comfortably
and it just worked
yeah when you did the seven shows at the
Beacon was it planned I'm gonna go out
and I'm gonna do these seven shows are
you like let's book a couple shows and
then they sold out I think we could do
another one I think we could do another
one exactly we we booked two shows there
and I think I actually think was three
at first we're gonna shoot the two and
then they sold and I know I had another
one and and then you know the demands
was such where we ended up doing seven I
didn't I didn't plan on doing seven it
just kind of worked out that way but New
York City has always been a really
really kind of hot spot for me and and
pretty amazing that's great yeah it's
phenomenal it's not easy to do at all
seven shows in the [ __ ] beacon I mean
that's that's a garden or more that's
more than a garden it is two Gardens
having do you think that way though like
when you're like okay I just did seven
beacons you like I should be doing
arenas I'm not an arena that's not you
know why that's not really where I want
to be great in arena though I think that
your act would be would because you are
animated I think you would do you be
fantastic in arena I appreciate that but
this is my thing with the arena at least
from my fans I think people are a little
more comfortable in a theater setting it
seems like it's a little bit more of a
classy or an event where a stadium seems
young it's basketball Stadium maybe the
seating is not as comfortable and and
the people are high up they really can't
see yeah you got some screens but I look
at it as more of an intimate you know no
more than 3,000 people I think to for a
comedy fan is a little bit more I look
at the same way but I keep it 200 seed
Club I told you I said you're ready for
125 Cedars I won't do it I said everyone
here has to leave with some of my DNA on
them
but you are I guess it does change the
dynamic when you're in a massive I've
seen a couple of comedians work I think
I think I've seen three or four like in
big arenas and it always seems to work
but they seem to be the right acts for
those venues I imagine if you if you're
not the right act for it would seem odd
or feel I guess is this what you've been
working toward like is this how you
envision things going when you start a
comedy like I want to be this level of
success or is it or the goal yeah was in
1998 when I moved on I said I just want
to do stand-up comedy for a living that
was the goal right if I could do this
and feed myself pay the rent and have a
nice little car or whatever it might be
I'd be happy I didn't really aspire to
be like you know anything that was you
know out of the ordinary I just wanted
to do what I enjoy doing for a living I
was always a shy guy I was more
comfortable with my family and telling
stories with my family I was never a
class clown or anything like that and I
just enjoyed getting up in front of the
class and making them laugh and then
sitting back down you're comfortable
with your family telling stories like
that and just like around your mom and
dad your aunts and uncles that's my like
little audience especially my mother if
I could make my mother laugh I feel like
that's a nice little seed so we could
play movies they okay tell me your test
audience yeah my mom if I could get her
going I know that that's that's
something I could explore would she give
you laughs now because I'd know that
you're doing this and be like oh yeah or
no it's more you know it's never like
it's very organic with my mother you're
just talking and I'll tell my mom I said
oh man you should use that and then
maybe I'll spell whatever the reason is
with my mother I have this
comfortableness of just telling a story
and kind of the the beats kind of work
it's work itself out over the phone
talking to her it's it's a it's kind of
like my little stage my family's never
said you should use that good I hear
things like don't tell anybody
why do you do you have that relationship
with your family now were you talk and
sit around the table and go for round no
but it's my fault not theirs they're
nice people I'm just a weirdo they don't
like transvestite stories it doesn't
ever tell what transsexuals daddy on
board
yeah they I don't know I don't have that
but again it's not their fault they're
really nice and they'd love it but I'm
just a [ __ ] weird shame filled idiot
yeah no I get that so i'ma say I admire
that like I think that's such a nice way
to be to have that comfort level with
you not this funny guy around your
family you know I'm a [ __ ] closed up
shell who just wants to hear them talk
about them I don't wanna talk about me
at all yeah what he'd been up to do you
really want to ask that question what
answer do you want I've been up to
hopefully not catching aids is Dennis
for alcohol outside he's there's a huge
fan all is you know Sebastian yeah that
he told me yesterday that he was a big
fan of yours and I noticed him 20
minutes ago why is a studio door yeah we
can bring him in we can bring him in
he's a diesel legendary DJ yeah dennis
is a legendary DJ he's previously been
banned from the show but first of all I
love that Dennis's comfort position is
just I'll just share Sebastian and
finding a mic I'm gonna Mike there's why
it's not empty while Jenny they are
doing just want to come over say hello
to the guest I know I know that buddy
just kind of stood dells you're gonna
talk in a thin air now you wanted to
share a mic with with Sebastian you told
me yesterday you're a huge fan right the
guy's fantastic he's one of my top three
italian comedians well top three Italian
he's kind of my ethnicity yes Cooper's
not as funny as the blacks the Italians
as far as circumcised guys I enjoy him
Sal Richards okay Wow old-school
Sebastian number one wow that's good
company because I'm Italian too so
everything you were talking about that
special we related to it Oh without a
doubt without it have you seen him live
no no life I'm gonna show him on TV
though he did seven shows at the Beacon
you couldn't get one ticket I can go buy
a ticket it's seven shows he was there
around the clock
Danny likes comps and radio it should be
a male should be
list yeah I know Melissa absolutely do
you like do you like non-italian
comedians oh yeah there's a few good
ones what do you like what's that
I like okay why you don't say all right
Oh Danny don't pray and I mean he just
fantastic because everything from
Brooklyn mm-hmm so you're Chicago's it's
very similar with the Italian people did
you grow up with my grandparents your
grandpa yeah they Meditech my
grandfather's name Sebastiano oh nice
I'm from Brooklyn so I love hearing your
stories about Chicago I mean you got to
get Boston Philly the Italians are all
the same yeah we call to me it's also
great I've never so racist in my life
people I call it gravy
I think gravy I think of brown turkey
gravy I know absolutely I think of life
it's all gravy did you agree that's
right by the way all Denny's doing is
pointing out differences as he's trying
absolutely girls you see they're the
same Ryan you're great I think what's
running down Denny's leg right now
blowing this the reason that bath is
blow and then we're watching this
special last week and my wife said I
like him he's clean he's very well him
sindbad sindbad is very clean also
Sinbad jolly callous was very clean do
you like Charlie Callas is the best shut
down the Dean Martin show yeah
Sebastian do you like that is like a
compliment like oh you know I like you
because you're clean or would you prefer
to just be a comedian
Oh clean that like me likely likely take
pride in it yeah okay all right it's
nice cuz it to be as successful as
Sebastian is reguarly Gaffigan who is
very also very funny being clean some
guys are cleaner cornballs but then
those guys were clean who are
legitimately funny it's really hard to
do right it's right to be that good for
that long without going into so many
different areas I mean that's it's it's
uh it's not easy
that's who you respect Dennis huh yeah
yeah I think so because it's tougher to
be clean you know I'm funny alright well
that's a direct shot at Jim Norton but
go on
no but he's just saying easy time stop
comedian I couldn't take my wife to see
Jimmy
whoa should I leave with me she'd be
smart to leave with anybody
so I would just say I love the guy he's
funny as hell yes not her cup of tea
yeah but you should continue relating to
Sebastian that was young so what else is
the same between Chicago and Brooklyn
and also choose your family members of
the IRA has bit I was talking he was
talking about his grandmother making
macaroni in in the basement yeah we
don't call it pasta called macaroon we
call it pasta okay another difference
that's okay that's good yeah that's good
show but my grandparents used to make
the wine in the basement oh yeah we
didn't for seven well maybe were just
like a little different but with our you
call abrasive Cillian bodies what I'm
Sicilian and my mother sandwich from
Napoli and you I'm calibrating of course
your Chilean okay so you have very very
little in common with nothing he's got
that gene yeah so your parents came
right over my father came when he was 15
my mother was born in the United States
so we were more Americanized than
anything else but to speak to your point
my grandparents were the type of
grandparents were you they lived in the
basement they cooked in the basement it
was all about food and real integrins
yeah you should you go back over it or
no have you ever been my father and I
went back to Sicily for the first time
I've ever been in six years and the
first time he's ever gone back in 50
just you and him yeah oh wow
so we went back to where he grew up and
you know he said it's where I played
foosball and this is where I learned how
to play soccer and I'm an emotional guy
right I'm like I take like an e it was a
little emotional well II and he was
nothing nothing affected nothing no
crying here and you know this is you
shingles on us it's just been shocked
that I'm in back in Sicily so that trip
he is now gone back every year since so
well I would never get emotional go to
my dad's old neighborhood I'd be like
let's get out of here there's a lot of
blacks Georgie said today much change -
yeah we got to wrap the show up for the
day why you know what this thing a bit
having that chance to go back with your
dad to Sicily it's just unbelievable
after you get to kill somebody then you
jump
back on the plane I got your button now
anybody know what yeah everything's good
family to our wedding once though and
Joe Colombo's their old tallien gangster
yeah and my father told me don't go
bother him no I wish your meal at all
he said don't bother him at all but we
grew up in Brooklyn where there was a
lot of those wise guys they used to work
you know not work at all I used to they
used to sit in front of the social clubs
remember John Gotti would talk about
these camera before like we lighten up I
was wrapping up and Ron did you know
Danny almost get involved in the Mafia
no so I would see you know my mom's like
that and I would walk in and know when
he was off I said dad how come these
guys don't work during the day and it
would just sit on chairs and drink and
play cards he goes you know don't bother
them don't talk it's the working man
that's the real heroes I was very
similar to what Barksdale yes right and
with HR they would they try to issue a
sin Chicago right yeah yeah yeah very
similar would they try to seduce you and
your father go ahead I'll talk to my
daughter he was almost a [ __ ] mop see
what's in it is more Jenny during the
week you I'll be back home for
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving Dennis yeah
look who's got a wrap up I'm dead are
you gonna come over trying to connect
all his radio lesson my mother makes
fresh sauce she doesn't buy that ragu or
anything it's fresh legs up gravy you
got nothing in common Center sauce we
just you have nothing in common
we're telling you to deal with Sicilian
you're not connecting you didn't connect
that's right guys make it ain't another
year he doesn't want to eat you stuff
your mom made in the basement yeah yes
you're good her own fetus have another
sip like the stopwatch make stuffed mush
water Janice yeah we're done the speedy
editor veal will you wrap up with the
toothpick you ever have those speediness
they call them veal rollatini the
Americans in speediness
Sebastien you think you can hang out
with Dennis outside absolutely yeah
Sebastian special yeah on Showtime now
available on demand
it's a why would you do that it's his
new special which he shot here in New
York at the Beacon